ja en eigenlijk
als je in de geschiedenis terugkijkt
dan krijgen mensen daar helaas bijna altijd spijt van
de tweede kabinet Rutte ging het precies vertellen
juist het was 1 zogenaamd 1 tweestrijd
tussen partij van de arbeid en VVD
en hoe voorkom het
en uiteindelijk gingen ze samen
in 1 kabinet zitten en dat weten
we zijn daar nog het land van aan het herstellen
bijvoorbeeld de verzorgingshuizen
we werden toegesloten en 1 hoop andere zaken
ik zou zeggen mijn advies
stem op 1 partij die past bij je hart
volg je hart
ik denk 1 sociale stem is 1 strategische stem
want hoe groter wij worden de sp
hoe groter de kans is
dat 1 kabinet zonder die VVD mogelijk is
ja en dan zouden we tenminste echt wat kunnen
doen aan de grote
tekorten in de publieke sector
of aan de woningnood toeslagen
sandaal waar we het net over hebben gehad
maar het belangrijkste is denk ik
volg je hart en stem voor je idealen